foreign
for years our family has fought for the
truth to come to light concerning his
murder
and we'd like our father to receive the
justice that he deserves
[Music]
the white man has to feel free to speak
his mind without hurting the feelings of
that negro and the so-called negro has
to feel free to speak his new mind
without hurting the feeling of the white
man
foreign
[Music]
there has been
speculation
as to who was involved
it was
confirmed and substantiated that the
government agencies
had factual evidence
and sculptory evidence
that they fraudulently concealed from
the men
who were wrongfully
convicted
for the assassination of Malcolm X
and you are technically
respect challenge
[Music]
we intend to
have vigorous
litigation of this matter to have
Discovery to be able to take depositions
of the individuals who
are still alive 58 years later to make
sure that some measure of Justice can be
given to Malcolm X's daughters who In
This Very Room were present with their
mother
where he was shot
at 21 times 17 bullets hitting him
[Music]